[MUSIC PLAYING]
NICOLAS DE CRISTOFARO:
Welcome to NET204--
Connecting Your Data
Center to Cloud--
Approach for Mission
Critical Network Reliability.
My name's Nick De Cristofaro.
I'm a customer engineer
here at Google,
specializing in
Google Cloud Network.
So first, let's talk
about Google's network.
So when we talk about
Google's network,
we're talking about a
massive global platform
as you can see--
134 points of presence, massive
investments in sub-sea cables,
connecting the world, as
you can see behind me,
all within a private
backbone network that we own
or that we have private
connectivity for.
The map here clearly
distincts some regions
that we have, of course also
future regions that we're
planning to launch, as well
as the mass point of presence
that we have to connecting
your data center to the cloud.
So let's talk a
bit about how you
connect Google to the cloud.
So connecting your
place to our place--
we actually have five ways of
connecting Google to the cloud.
We divide these into
two different sections,
public addressing and
private addressing.
The latter at the top is the
public addressing method,
which is actually
connecting Google
via various means of peering.
So direct peering
is one of them,
which offers the ability to
connect to Google via standard
peering that you would do
with an internet exchange,
essentially connecting
your public prefixes--
so public address blocks
that you would own--
to Google Cloud via
standard BGP peering.
On the top right-hand side,
we talk about carrier peering.
Carrier peering is
essentially the same means
of connecting to Google via
public addressing, however
through a carrier that
provides that connectivity.
So this is in case,
for example, you
do not have the connectivity
to Google directly
to be able to meet us at
our peering facilities,
you can do that
through a carrier.
On the bottom part, we speak
about private addressing.
Now, this is really interesting
for enterprise environments
where you want to
extend connectivity
from your on-premise environment
using private RFC 1918
addressing and connecting
directly to Google Cloud.
So that means being
able to reach directly
your on-prem workloads
to Google Cloud via two
means of connectivity.
And then of course, we have
the VPN option, which kind of
sits hybrid in the middle, which
provides a mix of connectivity
across public internet links
to do the private addressing,
extending your on-prem
environment to the cloud.
So when we speak of
private addressing,
we actually have two
methods of doing this.
Once it's dedicated
interconnect,
which is to directly connect
to Google Cloud via one
of our various
points of presence,
that means your
equipment is co-located
in a point of
presence, or you have
connectivity to our
point of presence
and establishing a
dedicated link to us.
The partner
interconnect offering
is actually to provide
connectivity, again, privately,
however, through a partner,
a service provider,
that is able to
extend the last mile
connectivity from your
on-premise environment
to Google Cloud.
In case you do not have
connectivity in one
of our points of
presence, you could
use a partner interconnect
to do that for you.
And as a hybrid
model, as I mentioned,
VPN is a way to connect
via public internet links.
And often, enterprises
start that way
before actually moving on
to purchase a dedicated
or a partner
interconnect offering.
And I will show you
later on actually
how seamlessly the transition is
done between a VPN connectivity
to Google Cloud
through a partner
or a dedicated
interconnect link.
So let's speak a bit about
the Cloud Interconnect.
But first, I'm
pleased to announce
that we are announcing 100
gig connections at our POPs.
So now you're able to connect
not only with 10 gigs,
but now with 100 gig connections
at our points of presence.
So Cloud Interconnect,
as I mentioned,
is a method to provide
access to private RFC 1918
addressing from your
on-prem workloads
directly to the cloud.
And it enables essentially
a hybrid cloud connectivity
model.
It does not require the use
of management of hardware VPN
devices because this is
something that you directly
connect your on-premise router
to us via the various POP
locations that we're located in.
So from the left hand side here,
we see dedicated interconnect,
as I mentioned.
We could do 10 gigs.
Now we can do 100 gigs.
We can provide an LACP bundle,
so a link group bundle,
from 8 times 10 gigs or 2 times
100 gigs [? per ?] provide
and transport circuits directly
to our cloud environment
from your on-premise
data center.
And a partner interconnect
provides dedicated bandwidth
for sub-circuit rates,
starting at 50 megabits
all the way to 10 gigs provided
through a service provider
network.
So here's the bit about how the
interconnect deployment looks
like.
So we can look at a dedicated
interconnect in this way.
We have a co-location
facility in the middle.
The co-location
facility is essentially
where you would meet us at
one of our points of presence.
So you may either have a
cage already established
in one of the facilities.
For example, some of
the Equinix facilities
is a very common
co-location facility
or any other
co-location facilities.
Or you can extend connectivity
there through any kind
of telco providers
that can extend
that connectivity to you.
And from that, you extend
your on-premise connection
to your data center, and
we provide connectivity
to our cloud network.
Now, here is a list of our
interconnect locations.
So as you can see, we're
present all around the world
in all the continents,
except, of course, Antarctica.
And then we have connectivity
with low latency links, which
is the dark green circles,
which are providing
very little [INAUDIBLE] access
to Google Cloud resources
if you need low latency
access between your workloads
and Google Cloud.
So that means you can
provide sub 5 milliseconds
on average from these sites to
any regions that are located
in these points of presence.
Looking at the partner
interconnect offering,
this is essentially
a model where
the partner is essentially
providing the connection
to Google, so partners
have established a partner
relationship with us already.
They've established
connectivity with us.
And they provide that last mile
connectivity to their clients.
So various partners offer that.
And if you're not
looking for something
at 10 gigs or potentially
higher throughput,
you would look at a partner
to offer that because they
can provide sub-circuit
rates from 50 megabits
all the way up to 10 gigs.
So they can provide that
solution and also one thing
that some partners
are able to offer
as well is that they
can minimize the router
requirements.
So you may not need a router
at the co-location facility
themselves, in case you
want to do something
like a multi-cloud
scenario and you
want to connect cloud to cloud.
Some partners offer the ability
to connect two clouds together
via virtual router offering.
So let's look at some of the
distinction between partner
and dedicated interconnect.
So why would you choose partner?
Why would you choose dedicated?
I talked to a lot of customers.
Depending on their use
case, it's very clear.
Partner is where you're
not able to have access
to our points of presence.
You're not physically co-located
in a point of presence.
You may not need to have
a requirement of 10 gigs.
You don't need 10 gigs, which
is the minimum that we can offer
with dedicated interconnect.
Therefore, a partner
will provide you
a sub circuit rate starting
from 50 megabits all
the way to 10 gigs.
And we can provide that via
VLAN attachments on our end.
You pay only for what you need.
SLAs require at least to have
two VLAN attachments, which
would terminate at two
different availability
zones within a metro area.
If you want to have an SLA
of three nines, and then
four nines, you would just
establish that across two
different metropolitan areas.
You can actually also establish
with partner interconnect,
you don't need to
be within one org.
We can actually extend the
connectivity from multiple orgs
because the partner
interconnect VLANs
can land in different
organizational units
within GCP.
For dedicated, it's
often used by customers
that require a high throughput.
They require a
minimum of 10 gigs.
The customer would essentially
meet us at one of our POPs
or again, extend connectivity
to one of our POPs
either via service
provider or meet
us physically in one of
our points of presence.
All the VLANs are
actually writing
on the same physical
link, so that
means that when you
establish VLAN attachments
through our Cloud console,
you would actually
establish the VLAN
attachments within
the same physical circuit
that's established with us.
SLAs, again, require at
least two connections
to one metro area across
two availability zones.
And then all VLANs need to land
in the same organizational unit
in GCP for dedicated
interconnect.
That means that you can
establish a project in GCP
within one org.
And that project can
share its resources,
but it's still bound
by the organization.
That's one of the advantages
that the partner interconnect
can do, is you can
actually span that
across multiple
organization if you need to.
So let's talk about
a few different ways
that you can actually
use interconnect
and some of the use cases that
our customers are using today.
So here's just an example,
again, of the private routing
that you can establish between
your on-premise infrastructure
and our cloud environment.
So essentially, you would
establish a BGP peer
via our offering, which is
called a Cloud Router, which
would be deployed
in the cloud region,
and then establish BGP peering
with your on-premise router
and exchanging prefixes.
In this case here, we have a
headquarter with an external
data center that has a
network of 192.168.55.0/24.
And we're advertising
that to the cloud region,
and the cloud region's
receiving that prefix over BGP
in the cloud region
as 192.168.49.0/24.
And we're advertising
that across.
So we can establish
that connectivity
through the Cloud Router,
which is our virtual BGP
speaker in the cloud and
your on-premise BGP speaker.
Another use case
that we've seen is
because of the concept
of global routing
and the concept of
our global network,
we're essentially able
to deploy within one VPC
multiple regions.
So that actually allows you
to connect with one router
that you deploy in one region.
You can actually reach natively
other regions within GCP.
So that means that we're able
to advertise prefixes that
would exist, let's say,
in a different region
than the region where the
Cloud Router is deployed.
And you can actually ride the
backbone of Google's network
to provide connectivity
between these regions.
You do not need to
duplicate your effort
in building separate
Cloud Router
instances in different regions.
This is done natively through
our global backbone network.
It's a flag that's enabled in
Cloud Router when you actually
deploy this.
It's called global routing.
It enables you to seamlessly
transition our network
and allow access
to remote regions
from the Cloud Router's region.
DNS is another one of our very
popular solutions as well.
Customers would like
to deploy on-premise.
They have on-premise
already at a DNS server
where they have post
names that they're
resolving for their
private resources on-prem.
And then they also want to
deploy resources in the cloud,
so they would use
Cloud DNS in the cloud,
specify specific A
records for different VMs
that they spin up
within the cloud,
and they would want their
on-premise environment
to also resolve host
names in the cloud.
So they would do that
via DNS forwarding.
We have both inbound and
outbound DNS forwarding,
which actually allows
you to resolve host names
from on-premise
workloads to the cloud
and also from the cloud
to on-premise workloads.
And we can allow that through
the means of interconnect.
So via either a dedicated
or partner interconnect
or through VPN,
we're able to extend
that connectivity via the
means of DNS forwarding.
Another great offering is
through the shared VPC model,
so within Google Cloud,
we're able to deploy
a model via shared VPC, which
essentially structures a host
project, which is essentially
the anchor for all
your networking resources
within the cloud.
So service projects do not
need to worry about networking.
They just need to
consume resources.
They can be development
teams that just
want to deploy applications.
They don't need to know about
the underlying networking
infrastructure, the routing, the
subnets, the firewall policies.
This is all done by a
centralized networking project
that would be managed by
generally a networking
team within your organization.
And that project would deploy
Cloud Router within a region.
And in that Cloud Router,
it could essentially
share the resources
of the interconnect
with the individual
service project.
So the service project would
consume networking resources
similar to subnets that you
would grant them access to.
And it can natively route
with any routing that's
available within
the host project
to your on-premise environment.
So again, this really
simplifies the model.
You don't need to duplicate
multiple interconnections
in each project.
You can actually
centralize this,
have a central
network administration
team that manages the
networking for your environment.
And the rest of the teams that
need to manage development
projects or other types
of service projects
do not need to worry
about networking.
And they're essentially
connected back
to your on-premise environment
via policies that you set.
Another use case is connecting
privately to Google services.
Google has many APIs
that can be exposed--
for example, Cloud Storage
or BigQuery-- that you may
want to utilize from on-premise.
And also, because you have
a dedicated link to Google,
it's a good benefit
to be able to use
that link with low latency
access, high throughput,
to be able to store data to,
let's say, a Cloud Storage
bucket or to load data
into BigQuery services.
So it can actually
advertise by a VIP range
back to your on-premise
environment with that API
that you can call.
And then you can
actually make calls
to Google Cloud
API services that
are available through this API.
So this supports
Google API endpoints.
There's a subset
of endpoints that's
currently supported with this.
And essentially, on-premise,
what you would do
is you'd do a DNS change to
rewrite the Google API's domain
to use a specific
VIP, a VIP range, that
allows you to connect
to these prefixes
through an interconnect link.
And you would advertise
that prefix, which,
as you can see in this example
here, it's 199.36.153.4/30,
on the Cloud Router back to
your on-premise environment.
So the Cloud Router
actually allows you
to program which routes you
would want to advertise.
And by advertising this range
making the necessary DNS
changes, you can
actually connect back
to on-prem to Google
API services natively.
And let's talk a bit about
high availability topologies.
So one circuit, as
I mentioned earlier,
does not give you
any kind of SLAs.
To have an SLA, you need to have
two circuits for a redundancy.
So in this case, we have
a co-location facility
which is located in
one metropolitan area.
That metropolitan area would
have two availability zones.
So to have any kind of
SLA, a 39 SLA with us,
you would need to
connect across two
of these metropolitan
availability
zones in a single metro.
So with BGP Graceful
Restart and Cloud Router,
we're able to provide means
of having high availability
across these two zones.
Now, for customers that
require very high availability,
we would want to
duplicate that effort
across two metropolitan areas.
So in this case, you may
have a metropolitan area
on the east coast, maybe
one on the west coast.
And you would be,
again, connected
across two availability
zones within
these metropolitan areas.
And that would provide
you a 49 SLA with us
to connect back to GCP.
And within GCP, you would deploy
a Cloud Router in one region
and a Cloud Router
in the other region
generally as close as possible
to where you are co-located
geographically.
So if it's on the
West Coast, you
would pick a region
on the West Coast.
And on the East Coast,
you would pick a region
on the East Coast.
With the means of
global routing,
as I mentioned
earlier, we're actually
able to then natively transit
our network in case of failure.
So if we were to lose
an entire region,
we're able to route
via the other region
to connect back to your
on-premise environment
via this model of deployment.
And now I'd like to introduce
my colleague Sasha on stage
to talk about high
availability Cloud VPN.
[APPLAUSE]
SASHA: Hi, I'm Sasha.
I'm one of the engineers
at the VPN team.
And if there is one thing
I learned in my years
working for VPN, it
is that reliability
is a critical feature of VPN.
Because if your connectivity
from your on-prem location
to GCP is down, you will feel
it across all the organization.
Now, the protocol
that we use to run VPN
is the industry
standard called IPsec.
It's pretty good when you
consider its encryption
capabilities.
But its ability to detect
and route around failures
is not so good.
So if anything fails on the
way from GCP to your location,
then your tunnel will be toast.
And we want to build a
more reliable connection.
And to do that, the way
is to use redundancy.
So you can set up
several tunnels
running in parallel
between the two locations
and hoping that if one is down,
the other will still be up.
So that gives you
some [INAUDIBLE]
but that's not enough.
Because if those tunnels
share any component
on the way from GCP
to your location,
if there is a fault
in that component,
again, your whole
connection will be down.
So not only you need to
provide a redundant connection,
you need to be able
to isolate failure
by making sure that
at no stage, there
is a single point of failure in
which your tunnel is working.
Now, us being cloud, this
is virtualized hardware,
so where do you even start?
So to do that, we
develop a new VPN product
called high availability VPN.
And for that, we have a new
kind of cloud VPN gateway,
slightly different
from the old one.
And what it does, it provides
you with two interfaces.
And you can think of them as
two different network clouds,
similarly to the
physical network clouds
you would put on your computer.
So if one of them is
burnt out, the other
is still continuing
to run your traffic.
But this is virtual.
So if you have two
tunnels attached
to two of the interfaces,
we will make sure
that they share nothing.
They share no line cards,
no network connections,
no machines, no switches.
Actually, being cloud, we are
pretty sure that they will not
even share a data center.
So they are pretty much
separated, and if one of them
goes down, the other
is still assured
and very likely to be working.
And then if a further scenario
happens, then a short time
after that, the
system will discover
that one tunnel went unhealthy
and switch all the traffic over
to the healthy tunnel.
Now, how much exactly that gives
you in terms of reliability,
it's a good question.
It's a function of how
good is the isolation
and how fast is the
process of switching over
from unhealthy tunnel
to the healthy one.
And we did this
analysis for our system.
And I'm happy to
announce that we
are going to provide
[? 49s, ?] which is 99.99%
regional availability.
So it means 4 and 1/2 minutes
of maximum monthly downtime,
or 53 minutes yearly.
And just a few notes--
so this is a regional product.
You do not need to
go multi-regional
to have this level
of reliability.
Just one region is enough.
You will be able to connect
just as with classic VPN
that we had.
You'll be able to
connect both GCP
to GCP, or to your
on-prem locations,
or even to another cloud.
The only requirement
that is mandatory now
and was optional
with classic VPN
is that we need the
VPN on the other side
to support dynamic routing.
If you think of it,
it makes total sense
because you want your system
to be able to failover,
to switch the traffic
from one path to another.
So it's natural.
And one last thing to
notice is that when
you're providing this
redundant connection,
you're actually having
twice as many tunnels
as you are sure to have in case
there is any system failure.
So if you watch the
observable capacity
that you have in your bandwidth,
then it will be twice as much
as you would have assured.
And so if there is any failure,
then your available bandwidth
will go down by a factor of 2.
And that's not the
time when you want
to discover that you actually
needed more tunnels than you
have configured.
So to have a consistent
experience of your bandwidth
staying constant all the
time, what we recommend
is to set up a VPN connection
in an active/passive
configuration, meaning that one
of the tunnels has priority.
And all the traffic flows
to it unless that fails,
and all the traffic switches
over to the other tunnel.
With dynamic routing again,
that's easy to set up.
You just use different
MED values, and that's it.
So to recap, we are
going to provide
[? 49's ?] availability.
This system is
currently in alpha.
it's going to launch
to beta next month.
And yeah, here's to more
traffic running more smoothly.
Nick, back to you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
NICOLAS DE CRISTOFARO:
Thank you, thank you.
OK.
So putting all that
into perspective now,
I will actually go
through a demo that
looks at a common
enterprise use case, where
we have an enterprise that
starts with a VPN tunnel.
Here, for example, I
have a customer project.
I have an IPsec
tunnel connected back
to a customer router on-prem.
I set, as Sasha
was talking about,
the MED values, which
are important in terms
of traffic engineering
that we're doing
within the interconnect model.
So in this case, I have a
standard MED value of 100.
And then I would like to
set up another connection.
This other connection would
be a dedicated or partner
interconnect offering.
And then I don't want traffic to
switch over to this connection.
So I create a
connection, create it
with a lower MED value of
1,000, and I establish a link.
Now, once that link
is established,
traffic will not
seamlessly switch over yet
because the value of
the MED priorities
are preferred over
the VPN tunnel,
then from the
interconnect connection.
Now, to do a traffic
switchover, it's very simple.
We just switched the MED values
between the VPN connection
and the interconnect
connection by swapping them.
And then the traffic
seamlessly moves over.
So now I have a VPN connection
that can be used as a backup.
I can keep it online
in case I need it.
But right now, my
traffic would actually
be routed across a dedicated
interconnect or partner
interconnect link.
So here's the topology of what
we're doing for this demo.
So I actually have a HA VPN
deployed with two interfaces.
They're both deployed in
active/passive right now
with MED value of
100, MED value of 200,
so active/passive
on the VPN link.
And then I have my
interconnect links
with higher MED values,
1,000 and 1,200.
And they're connected back
to an on-premise environment,
which I'm running a ping
test between that and a VM
within GCP.
So you can see
here I have-- this
is my Cloud Console
with this project.
I just showed the topology.
So we have here the interconnect
session and the VPN sessions.
You can see here the 1,000 and
the 1,200 as advertised route
priority.
And we can see here the 100
and 200 for my VPN connections,
my VPN tunnels.
So here, I'm running a ping
test between an on-prem workload
and a VM and GCP.
As you can see here, we
have kind of sporadic pings
between 20 to 30 milliseconds.
This is running
across the internet.
This is a VPN tunnel.
It's unpredictable due to the
path nature of the internet.
So I can't really
rely on some guarantee
in terms of milliseconds.
It's pretty sporadic.
It's flipping up and down.
I want to now
switch traffic over
to a dedicated interconnect
link to have higher throughput
and also lower latency.
So here, I'm just running
a script, which is actually
going to set the
priorities, swap them
between the interconnect
and the VPN tunnels.
So really what I'm doing is
I'm switching the priorities,
both on the VPN side in GCP--
both VPN interconnect
side on GCP
and also on-prem from
my on-prem router
to make sure that we're
updating on both sides
so that it's
symmetrical traffic.
Of course, it's important to
do that so that traffic runs
both symmetrically
between the peers.
And once that's
actually completed,
then we should see that traffic.
The latency is going to be
reduced quite significantly
because we're going to go across
a dedicated interconnect link
with much lower latency
and higher throughput.
And as you can see now, we've
actually lowered it down.
Once it stabilizes,
it should be around 8,
9 minutes milliseconds
when traffic is running
across the interconnect.
As you can see now, it's
around 9 milliseconds.
So that traffic seamlessly moved
over to the interconnect link,
instead of the VPN tunnel.
And as you can see,
I've seamlessly
transitioned traffic.
There's no packet loss.
Easy to do.
Now you can move
traffic over, and you
have traffic riding across
the interconnect link.
And if we look at the Cloud
Console, and we refresh it,
now we see that the
priorities have been swapped,
so the interconnect session
now has 100 and 200.
That's the preferred
path, active/passive path
across the
interconnect, and 1,000,
1,200 for the VPN tunnels.
So they're still there in
case we need it as a backup.
In case there
would be a failure,
we can still transition traffic
across the interconnect.
So it's that simple to be able
to do a migration between VPN
and interconnect seamlessly
between your enterprise
and GCP.
And with that, that
is the end of my demo.
I'd like to introduce Steve
Olson from The Home Depot
and talk about his
interconnect experience.
Thank you.
STEVE OLSON: Thank you.
NICOLAS DE CRISTOFARO: Yep.
[APPLAUSE]
STEVE OLSON: Hey,
my name is Steve.
But everyone calls me Steve
O. You'll have to excuse me.
My voice is a little bit
under the weather today.
I caught something here,
but we will push forward.
I've been with The Home
Depot for 12, 13 years, which
means I'm incredibly
tired, and I've
seen lots of different things.
We like to say we've
seen a lot of changes
in Home Depot in
the last five years,
probably more than we've
seen in the past 10 or 15.
And that really goes to speak
to our digital transformation,
things that we've done.
We've really put IT first.
It wasn't always the case.
When I first started, IT
was kind of a backseat.
Now IT's kind of a
front-seat driver.
And we've really done this
strategy called interconnected
retail.
And it's really an
omnichannel strategy
that lets our customers buy
online, pick up in store,
buy online, ship to their
home, buy in the store.
All of that kind
of merges together
to give the customer the choice.
And one of the big strategies
that we played with first
was the cloud.
GCP we chose to do
e-comm for, and we
have a journey that
kind of uses the tools
that the guys have
been talking about
and how we connect it to GCP.
But first, I'm going
to start with some base
facts about Home Depot.
I won't read everything
on this slide,
but Home Depot was founded 1978.
Last year, we did
$108 billion in sales.
Dot com was up 22%
in sales, and there's
some dot com guys here
I'll put in front.
I think in the last
five years, six years,
we've actually
increased dot com sales
by a billion dollars
almost every single year.
A lot of that growth has
been in our cloud space.
We completely
replatformed dot com,
we'll talk about that
in just a second.
We have over 150 supply
chain facilities.
We have over 2,000
stores spread out
across Canada, the
US, and Mexico.
And of course,
400,000 associates.
What a lot of
people don't realize
is we do have a big IT presence.
We have over 3,000
IT associates.
We hired just under 1,000 last
year, and we're still going.
We have offices all across the
country from our various brands
to define Home Depot and
companies that we use.
And with that, I'll start
with our actual strategy
and how we started
with the cloud.
So what kind of led up
to a distributed model
for us is really just starting
with e-commerce first.
And around 2014, we completely
re-platformed the website.
And it was decided that we
would go from an on-prem model
to in the cloud.
And some of the reasons
are the classic reasons
that you would hear.
Right?
We were building our
on-premise infrastructure
for sales that would be
around Thanksgiving or Black
Friday or Father's Day.
And you'd build this
infrastructure to the point
where you're using it
for those days only.
And then the rest of the
year, it sits stagnant.
So we really wanted a more
on-demand infrastructure
that could scale.
And of course, the
cloud came into that.
It took multiple years to do.
And really, this is going
to be a condensed timeline,
but I'll explain exactly
how we got there.
One of the first things
is data movement.
How do we actually get data from
our on-prem to the GCP cloud?
And the first thing, of
course, is before we even
get going with lots of projects,
is just the basic internet.
So we had basic
proxies and internet.
And that doesn't
scale incredibly well.
What if you need
private services?
Just like they talked about
in the slides before--
VPNs and interconnects.
We first started using
VPNs, and I've kind of
got a love/hate
relationship with VPNs.
Some people like them.
I hate VPNs.
And I'll explain that
for a few reasons.
I mean, VPNs suck.
Let's face it.
But if that's all you can
do, that's all you can do.
We actually use static routes.
There was no Cloud
Router at this point.
This was around 2015.
So we were stuck with static
routes and no redundancy.
And it worked, except it
terminated on-prem here,
and then it terminated
inside the cloud.
It basically did
what it needed to do.
But we needed
something more robust.
And we needed to scale
higher And so the problem
is with VPN, which is
something we'll talk about.
MTU-- how many of you have ever
dealt with frame size issues
and MTU problems with VPNs?
It's like yeah, everyone's
hands going up, right?
MTU is a terrible
thing to deal with.
And it's not Google's
fault. But Google, you
have to have fragmentation
before encapsulation.
And if you ever dealt with
firewalls, and packet captures,
and wire captures for why
something doesn't work,
does your application even
support fragmentation?
Does it know it's
going to be fragmented?
I just need an Advil
just talking about it.
We dealt with that so long that
we needed to get rid of that.
Speed and latency is
another big thing.
One of the big things that I
found about speed and latency
is that if you talk
to your customers,
sometimes they don't know what
the difference between that is.
They might say, I
need something quick,
but does quick
mean I need to load
a terabyte of data in a day?
Or I need a connection to a
database in 5 milliseconds?
Sometimes you have to actually
lead that conversation there
to see exactly what
they care about.
All right, SLA and the
internet in general,
that's a big thing as well.
You come in one day and your
connection across the internet
is 30 milliseconds, and
the next day, it's 45.
We've all dealt with that.
We actually made a diagram that
basically shows cold potato,
hot potato routing to explain
to our application developers
and our consumers what
it's like that, yes, we
have internet
connections to the cloud,
but we don't go straight there.
I don't own the
infrastructure in the middle.
And getting their heads
wrapped around the fact
that yes, I may
leave here, but I
don't know what some
tier one provider does
with it after the fact.
And that's how we
explain that to them.
So let's deal with
the VPN issue first.
So we really wanted to have
a way that the VPN be better.
We couldn't fix the
MTU immediately,
but we could fix some of the
speed and latency problems.
So this is where
we really started
discussing peering facilities.
So we actually
came up with, if we
could get the VPNs
closer to Google,
we can actually get
performance better--
so speed, latency,
reliability, SLA.
All right, so we came up with
peering centers on the East
and on the West Coast.
Those are the first good
choices because a lot
of the infrastructure for things
that we're using are there.
And we have well-defined
lanes used now.
So instead of
using the internet,
we own these private circuits
between some of our data
centers directly to
these peering centers.
So I can tell my application
developers and all my teams,
I know what you're going to
get from a latency perspective.
I know this is 15.
I know this is 40.
And we don't have to
worry about the internet.
So what we really did is--
revisiting the first slide--
is we moved the VPN connections
all the way out to the colo
there in the peering centers.
And the VPN's still
inside the project.
So the internet is
not used, right?
But reliability
and SLA go way up.
Speed is now
actually even better,
because now we have
direct connections.
So we're running the VPN
basically on the last mile.
We're not running it
across the country
and hoping that it gets there.
We have our own private
circuits that gets us there.
So the real redundancy
actually still isn't here yet.
So we actually started
doing multiple VPNs,
but without Cloud Router,
and static routes,
and trying to scale that.
Yeah, that didn't work either.
So we needed to do something
even better than that.
It actually worked well
enough that we basically
started adding more.
People liked it so much
that we added a couple more.
So now we have 7
milliseconds and 3.
And we actually have vendors
and application owners
that test this and can get
connections straight to GCP
within 10 milliseconds.
All right, and so once we
started doing that, we thought,
well, interconnect beta started.
And if we could get
the interconnect on,
we could get rid of the VPNs.
So now we're going
to fix the VPN issue.
That's still a
problem with the MTU.
So what happens is the
interconnect beta comes,
Cloud Router comes, and we
have now an interconnect
plus a direct connect.
So at each of the
peering facilities,
we have four different cables.
We have two for public
access, two for interconnect,
and depending on what
the project needs are,
they can do private
access, or they
can do public access over
our own infrastructure
to get there.
The internet's not involved.
And of course, with
dynamic routing,
the redundancy is
much more seamless.
And it fails over much easier.
So with that, we
basically grew even more.
We actually added another
facility this year.
And all these slides
back each other up.
They were talking about
mission critical reliability.
We built this in such a way
that when we have circuit issues
and some of these go down, our
application orders don't even
notice.
Because if they're
multi-region and multi-attached
to different interconnects
and use Cloud Routers,
it automatically fails over.
We've scaled to there now,
but we're even adding more.
And really, it's
not just GCP either.
The journey to actually getting
us connected directly to GCP
led us to other things.
We're using it for
other providers as well
and other vendors and partners
of us, and even the internet
itself.
So just the concept
of getting to GCP
let us to this distributed
regionalized network
that we can use.
And with the combination
of new technologies
like SD WAN and
things like that, we
can have our remote
sites, our stores,
our distribution centers,
we can have them all
come to the closest
peering facility
and use Cloud Services, or
use the internet, and things
that they might need.
They don't need to come
back to the main offices.
They need to go directly
to the internet.
We can control it all in a
centralized, regionalized
manner.
And so, with that being
said, what we're doing next
is we're investigating
what they talked about
in the last few slides.
It is private services
via these channels,
meaning using our
private space to contact
BigQuery and things like that.
We're really interested
in shared VPC,
and we're going to continue
deploying more peering centers
and keep using the
multi-regional model, and Cloud
Routers, and interconnects.
And we'll probably even
expand to more peering centers
in Canada and Mexico this year.
This model's proved
extremely well.
Our customers like it.
And we will continue to do that.
With that being said,
that is my talk.
[MUSIC PLAYING]